hi are you a sociopath have you been
caught with your pants down figuratively
or literally in some cases do you want
to rejoin your moral community and win
back the respect of your peers but don't
want to admit that you're wrong well
you've come to the right place today
we're gonna learn about the art of the
non-apology we're gonna take you from
this I did not have sexual relations
with that woman to this
[Applause]
from this hey everybody it's me Kathy
Griffin I am just now seeing the
reaction of these images I made a
mistake and I was wrong to this it's
been eight years oh it's your this month
that picture was released by the way I
take the apology back and if you're
lucky from this and when you were
started they let you do it to this what
a great honor to be able to introduce
for the first time ever anywhere the
45th President of the United States of
America Donald J Trump
all right let's do this number one don't
apologize let's start with the bread and
butter have you tried not apologizing
this is called the John Wayne approach
oh no sir just out by the waterfall but
I'm sorry never apologize mister it's a
sign of weakness
this is often perceived by your
supporters as being strong and powerful
you don't have to apologize no matter
what you do this technique is endorsed
by Donald Trump we are not going to
apologize for America no more apologies
and before you say there goes crazy
Trump changing American politics to be
insensitive
just remember this has been an American
stands for pretty much forever I'll
never apologize for the United States of
America ever I don't care what the facts
are no matter what the facts are
this is America number two account don't
apologize okay so if not apologizing
isn't an option you've really stepped in
the doodoo try accounting this is when
you don't apologize you explain the
context of when you messed up and that
supposedly justifies the action if they
hadn't bought the liquor you wouldn't
have been drinking and if you hadn't
been drinking you wouldn't have sent
those embarrassing photos of yourself
Roseanne put on a clinic of accounting a
few weeks ago when she said oh no I
didn't mean to tweet something people
interpret it as racist I was on ambien
which made me sleep tweet whoo Roseanne
has her CPA in accounting great stuff
Zann sets the bar number three
apologized but don't change now this
next one is a long con you're going to
say that you're sorry but then commit a
string of activities that show that you
really haven't changed this next example
is a little long I of course am talking
of Anthony's weiners apology this is him
in 2011 when the scandal first breaks
last Friday night I tweeted a photograph
of myself that I intended to send us a
direct message is part of a joke to a
woman in Seattle so today I'm announcing
my resignation from Congress and two
years later he tries to repair his image
look I made some big mistakes and I know
I let a lot of people down but I've also
learned some tough lessons
breaking news I'm responsible for this
behavior that led us to be in this place
I want to again say how very sorry I am
to anyone who has received their was
receiving end of these messages this is
a pretty risky maneuver it can backfire
pretty hard so please be careful at this
one number four clarified don't
apologize another tactic is to say that
your accuser misunderstood or
misinterpreted you you really meant
something else for this example take a
look at megyn kelly confronting donald
trump about his on record history of
misogyny i don't want to sound too much
like a chauvinist but you wouldn't have
your job if you weren't beautiful it's
very sad I'd look at right in that fat
ugly face she's got a little bit large
a person who is flat chested is very
hard to be attempt she ate like a pig
but what does he do does he sit there
and take it does he apologize
no he clarifies it he says I wasn't
talking about women I was talking about
Rosie O'Donnell you've called women you
don't like fat pigs dogs slobs and
disgusting animals your Twitter account
only Rosie O'Donnell
[Applause]
this can be extremely effective on to
the next example
number five issue a statement but never
actually say sorry so let's say you're
Hillary Clinton someone running under
the banner of women's rights and you
find yourself in trouble for not firing
a 2008 campaign advisor who is accused
of sexual harassment well what is she
gonna do
watch this play-by-play she issues a
series of tweets where she explains
herself but notice she never uses
apologize or sorry anywhere in here
now you amateurs out there pay special
attention to this next part see we call
this the Washington Double Down she gets
called out for that and then she goes on
to explain herself further in a really
long Facebook apology but still doesn't
use words like apologize are sorry
so it looks like she's apologizing but
she really isn't now before we move on
to our last type of non apology in this
video let's take a second to analyze why
someone might use non apologies a non
apology is used for two reasons first
apologizing is all about not making
excuses taking blame and putting
yourself in the hands of the offended
this is difficult if you're in a
position of power it can make you feel
weak it can cause legal issues because
apologizing means you're admitting guilt
and some people simply don't like
admitting when they're wrong the second
reason is maybe in your mind you haven't
committed a large enough offense to
warrant an apology for this reason you
might issue a half-hearted sorry
different people have different
thresholds for what deserves an apology
either way it's worth knowing that if
you do decide to go the route of the
non-apology they often come off as
unsatisfying at best and unfeeling at
worst as you may have noticed in this
video humans have a natural instinct for
sensing if an apology is sincere and if
the apologizer is just trying to weasel
their way out of the offense if you
doubt this think of how unsatisfying
these phrases are I'm sorry you got
offended or if I hurt anybody then I
apologize still not apologies do have
their place sometimes they have social
utility and sometimes they're all you
can do as Edwyn bad Estela points out in
his book sorry about that the language
of public apology
to illustrate this he brings up a
historical example when in 1968 during
the Vietnam War North Korean forces
captured the USS Pueblo a ship gathering
intel on the North Koreans North Korea
claimed the Pueblo had crossed the
territory lines making them fair game
for capture while the u.s. insisted it
hadn't the crew was tortured and forced
to sign confessions and North Korea
threatened that if the u.s. didn't give
a written apology for straying into
their territory that killed a crew after
being stalled in diplomacy for almost a
year
Gilbert Woodward the Army Major General
at the time signed an agreement that the
u.s. was at fault while simultaneously
releasing this remark my signature will
not and cannot alter the facts I will
sign the document to free the crew and
only to free the crew this non apology
that was signed by Woodward is a perfect
example of how in sincere apologies can
sometimes be the only answer the next
day the pueblos crew was released safely
but now that we've talked about why
someone might use a non-apology how they
come off as insincere and the rare cases
where they're needed let's move on to
our final example number 6 I'm sorry but
apologies let's say you're Caitlyn
Jenner you've just rammed a 69 year-old
from behind with your car
so you're being held accountable for
murder how do you get out of it this one
we're gonna play along at home a say
you're sorry be blame it on the
paparazzi see settle the lawsuit with
your enormous wealth and don't face jail
time or D all of the above yes that's
right to all of you who guess D you are
correct you do it all when you can't
totally dodge the apology you can say
you're sorry but that it wasn't all your
fault
this is what Caitlyn does she says she's
sorry but the paparazzi were the ones
distracting her and they should also be
held responsible she has it all figured
out and for the record she never face
jail time totally got away with
manslaughter
he just said manslaughter get him
[Applause]
a lot of my recent remarks got up here
before you to say that I'm deeply deeply
sorry
[Music]
thanks for watching that video first of
all music Mecca 83 you've seen him on
here before incredible guy go check him
out we've got a new artist named Ibrahim
I think so you pronounce it anyway
incredible producer if you like his
sounds go check them out all the links
to the music are down below discussion
go to the reddit will have a thread I
also want to discuss with you guys
patreon I've realized after doing this
channel for a little while that that's
gonna have to be the main income source
for this channel
I just don't release videos fast enough
I prefer quality I prefer spending my
time on videos so that's gonna be have
to be the direction of the channel so
you will see more pitches for that I
apologize if you're annoyed by that but
the patrons had that have been
supporting me those guys are the kind of
the lifeblood of this channel so I'm
pushing more towards that along those
lines I want to change up kind of what
we do with that so as you know we have
two tiers some of you know we have the
proletariat and we have the burgeois zee
proletariat is $1 a month version onesie
is five dollars a month in the past I
haven't done anything with it I want to
change that I'm not exactly sure how I'm
going to but for now I want to try this
if you are currently supporting me or
you are considering supporting me go to
patreon I'm going to create a thread and
I'm asking for input on what you'd like
to see would you like to see perks would
you like to see more recognition would
you like to see nothing at all I need
your feedback to know kind of the
direction I want to go with this what
makes you want to support your input
really means the world to me so please
go and put in your two cents one last
little announcement and then we're done
I'm about to leave for my honeymoon so I
will be gone for about little over a
week and then I will be back I think I'm
going to do a look back at one of my
first viral videos for the next one
maybe
that's something people got mad at me
for so look forward to that thank you
for watching